françois durpaire historien spécialiste
des états unis et auteur du livre les
états unis pour les nuls aux éditions
first
bonsoir françois durpaire merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
l'a vu le vote anticipé semble mobiliser
les les américains est ce que c'est le
cas selon vous exactement il ya 50
millions d'américains qui ont déjà voté
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que quand
on va commencer à commenter l'élection
le 3 devant l'élection elle sera aux
deux tiers passées parce que les
politologues américains estime qu'au
moment où on va commencer à parler de
cette élection du 3 novembre
eh bien deux tiers des américains ont
déjà voté et elle reste que ça on dit
cap
c'est principalement des démocrates
parce qu'elle certains états qui demande
l'appartenance partisane principalement
des démocrates et on sait qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont voté ça c'est
très important parce que c'est vu comme
un bon signe par les démocrates que les
jeunes de 18-29 ans et massivement voté
plus par exemple corps 2016 et on le
voit aussi un à travers ce reportage que
les les afro-américains sont sont
incités à aller voter puisque le jour du
vote beaucoup travaillent et ne peuvent
pas se permettre de se déplacer dans
dans les bureaux de vote ça aussi ça va
être un enjeu il sont mobilisés les afro
américains
oui c'est vrai qu'on regarde en ce
moment ce qu'on appelle les blocs
électoraux donc on regarde les minorités
on voit qu'effectivement l'accent est
mis du côté démocrate sur la
mobilisation de la minorité afro
américaine on voit que la minorité
hispanique c'est un peu différent ça
dépend peut-être des états mais que
donald trump fait bien chez les
hispaniques catholique alors on se
demander ce qui va faire mieux qu'il ya
quatre ans ou moins bien il ya des états
donc c'est très important notamment la
floride et le nevada
puis à d'autres groupes qu'on va suivre
de très près les seniors un effort est
fait chez les seniors des deux côtés en
ce moment avec beaucoup de publicité qui
sont consacrés à cet électorat de plus
de 65 ans pour l'instant plus 10 chez
joe biden pour les seniors et puis
d'autres gros par exemple les femmes les
femmes sans diplôme avaient voté donald
trump
quatre ans les femmes senti comme pour
l'instant dans les enquêtes d'opinion
s'apprêtent à voter plutôt joy ride et
ses votes par anticipation risque de
compliquer quelque peu l'annoncé des
résultats françois durpaire
oui alors il ya deux hypothèses pour la
soirée électorale la première hypothèse
c'est que le les sondages actuels sont
justes et que joe biden à huit points
d'avance national gagne d'état par
exemple comme la floride et ça lui
permettrait d'aller assez vite vers la
victoire
deuxième hypothèse c'est plus compliqué
c'est beaucoup plus serré on sait qu'au
niveau des enquêtes état par état
on n'est qu'à plus quatre ans qu'on est
dans la marge d'erreur pour joe biden et
si donald trump venait par exemple à
gagner la floride est bien là ça
pourrait se prolonger en oeuvre et ce
qu'on appelle le mirage rouge c'est à
dire qu'on aurait à commenter une carte
qui serait principalement rouge parce
que ce sont les républicains qui se
serait déplacée cette ce jour là et au
fur et à mesure des jours vous rappelle
qu'on peu dépouillé jusqu'à dix jours
après il ya des états qui accepteront
des enveloppes
dix jours après le 3 novembre même si on
vote évidemment le 3 novembre à vous
pouvez pas envoyer votre vote le 4
novembre et bien jusqu'à dix jours on va
dépouiller et peut-être que là on va
voir une carte rouge devenir bleu ce
qu'on appelle le mirage rouge
et là c'est le scénario catastrophe pour
les démocrates qui se disent dans ce cas
là est ce que donald trump accepterait
son éventuelle défaite et qu'en
penserait la cour suprême est ce que la
cour suprême de ne dirais pas d'un tract
a gagné vous savez que demain on va
dominer la j je pars est à la cour
suprême il ya un vote du sénat très
important et ça pourrait faire 6 contre
3 pour les conservateurs et rentrons
dans le fond de la campagne donald trump
qui fait jusqu'à cinq étapes par jour il
est dans les états clés pour tenter de
convaincre
weedon un trac il ya une stratégie très
très clair ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que cette année on a un point
quand même un peu particulier c'est que
le corps byden à trois fois plus
d'argent aujourd'hui
que le camp trump c'est un peu
particulier la levée de fonds a été très
très efficace du côté démocrate
comment deux d'entre eux s'en sort comme
il peut pas vraiment dépenser sur des
publicités nationales notamment les
démocrates vous avez vu les spots 30
secondes entre chaque match de ligue de
football américain au niveau national eh
bien il va faire la presse locale donc
il fait le bon coup beaucoup de meetings
et il espère que la presse locale lui
donne l'occasion de faire de la
publicité gratuite sauf que le problème
c'est que cette presse locale bien elle
et pas forcément très positif parce que
on reproche à donner un train de mettre
encore en danger la vie des américains
avec ses fameux 8 et où on le voit sur
les images
tout le monde n'a pas de masquer la
distanciation social n'est pas respectée
et donc tout ça évidemment pose plus
problème et les titres sont assez
négatif en revanche il a pris un thème
qui semble porter l'énergie il ya
quelques heures vous savez il ya le
débat contre joe biden ou joe biden a
fait un peu cette gaffe en disant bien
l'industrie pétrolifère
on va arrêter les subventions fédérales
et et donald trump a dit il veut
détruire l'industrie pétrolifère et
détruire aussi le gaz c'est la question
de la fracturation hydraulique ça paraît
un peu technique mais ça veut dire
quelque chose de très concret quand on
habite en pennsylvanie en caroline du
nord quand on habite dans des états où
cette industrie est importante
donin 30 pensent que cet angle-là peut
lui permettre de gagner 6 à cet état clé
donc là c'est l'angle de l'énergie et ça
lui permettrait aussi de gagner
penses tu es l'électorat senior alors là
il a dit quelque chose dans ses derniers
discours un peu un peu invraisemblable
mais c'est un peu comme ça qu'il fait
souvent
il a dit aux personnes âgées vous
n'aurez plus avec joe weiden de
chauffage l'hiver et vous n'aurez plus
de climatisation l'été parce qu'il est
contre l'énergie
il va détruire votre énergie américaine
merci
beaucoup françois durpaire pour votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste des états unis
et auteur du livre les états unis pour
les nuls aux éditions first merci
beaucoup que l'on voit justement à
l'écran